l'argumentaire français ne tient pas
c'est en résumé ce que conclut le comité
des droits de l'enfant des nations unies
sur le refus de paris de rapatrier les
enfants de djihadistes retenu
principalement dans les camps d'al hall
et de roches au nord-est de la syrie
d'après le journal libération l'onu a
tranché la france est responsable
juridiquement de ses enfants
mieux encore elle a les moyens de les
protéger en organisant leur rapatriement
leurs conditions de détention représente
un risque imminent d'atteinte
irréparable à leur vie à leur intégrité
physique et mentale et à leur
développement
ils seraient environ 250 enfants
français dans les camps de syrie
malnutrition conditions sanitaires
déplorables mais aussi risque
d'endoctrinement l'avis du comité pointe
l'extrême vulnérabilité de ses enfants
la france de son côté a toujours affirmé
qu'elle n'avait aucune juridiction sur
les autorités kurdes qui gère les camps
d'al hall et de roches pour le moment le
pays mise sur la politique du cas par
cas une volonté réaffirmée par le chef
de l'état lors de sa visite au kenya en
mars dernier pour ce qui est des enfants
à c'est une approche au cas par cas qui
est menée en particulier en lien avec la
croix rouge internationale
elle c'est une approche humanitaire qui
est suivie avec beaucoup de vigilance en
lien avec tous les acteurs qui sont sur
le terrain
si l'hexagone ne change pas de position
et ne se plie pas au droit international
il pourrait être condamné par le comité
des droits de l'enfant
mais cet avis pourrait aussi être
utilisée devant la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme
cette dernière a été saisie par des
grands-parents dont les deux petits
enfants sont en syrie si la france était
condamnée elle aurait pour obligation le
rapatriement de ses enfants est
peut-être le versement de dommages et
intérêts à la famille